they got a lot of things wrong in that
they expected that there would be a
revolution in energy so that we would
have jetpacks and flying cars when when
we got instead were a revolution and
information which led to cell phones and
laptop computers energy is limited by
the atoms and how they interact with
each other and the chemical binding
between them unless you're going to go
nuclear whereas information is pretty
much limited only by our cleverness in
how to store and transmit it the
information revolution was enabled
thanks to the developments of
semiconductor and solid-state physics
which in turn were created or made
possible thanks to the discovery of
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics is
the branch of physics that deals with
how atoms interact with each other and
how they interact with life back in 1926
bugle Gernsback publishes the first pulp
magazine devoted exclusively to science
fiction amazing stories also publishing
in 1926 urban charting er publishing the
Schrodinger equation that would form the
foundation of quantum mechanics so
there's these two visions of the future
that start off in 1926 really within
months of each other one leads to the
fantasy world of death rays and the
other leads to the reality of laser
you